okay we're back and maybe we'll find out
why that esos right you know maybe but
don't count on it
okay continue that's a hair it's also
dark away face pack of marshmallow land
yeah okay oh great some burning books
here's something I got it's right there
any leaves again
since like 10 times already
okay but this is like marshmallow land
that light Becca area cow now fortune
teller
it's disgusting duh and during a red
territory
what the heck is this that's a courtroom
okay no right here weird word hmm again
I wake up and I'm bathroom hem right
that was have I hey what what the heck
did I mess up my here well like skipping
around okay no wait is this downstairs
office what the heck is going on now in
case of Susan Talon Theodore doused
murder suspect Edward got information
they keeps myself time okay so this is
like after and he like killed everybody
so quiet good so maybe you would tell us
about your authorial therapy what do you
think mr. Dow can you hear me it's
better now isn't it
so can we continue great did you know
that Susan Dow was pregnant general
Torres bone shifts are hitting the key
for the door switch safe place I'll tell
him anything let's drive him doctor well
okay where is that where is that that
where did he hide it
jaysus take like ten years now
okay these are all closed at the ground
here oh great now I'm never gonna find
it
what
okay anything on here let's say no okay
time is up and over here
uh-oh I've got that ducky I've got that
ducky okay uh-huh why does God not hear
what's in here
tell when the walls
okay so they haven't gotten anything out
of Eddie guess he's crazy
what okay turn it right until I get the
X then turn left nothing right again
wait now no no where's the X
turn right until the X and then turn
left then turn right
what's the X
have sex how I love this target okay
have fun with the excess shame I had
claimed but spread syphilis Jesus ain't
numbers in here
what seven
that's number seven you put the first
one is weight three okay it's three
something seven three to seven
okay thirty-seven I got this perfect ow
well so what's gonna scare me now it
just suddenly got so quiet there we go
as when the scare start
I think it was over here yep I think
it's in the jail cell
can I go anything I don't like how this
uphill on your match
that's just so lazy
what's going on here
I hereby open the trial against Edward
about Susan towel and the theater Dallas
burger who the prosecutor and counsel
wish to say anything before the trial
has started I would like to enclose the
report about my clients insanity to the
evidence as well as recordings made by
dr. Dell during the therapy mr. Edward
could you tell us about the relation
that was between you and mrs. Susan Dow
dr. Stephen dows wife that tried to cure
you I would like to enclose documents
from Susan's autopsy to the evidence
basing on these your honor has been to
the jury soon I Eddie you know you asked
me
father is Eddie
[Music]
what wait so Eddie got in the enclosed
evidence Your Honor may read about many
difficult cases that have been cured by
the defendant he was trying to cure his
protege at any cost to ease the pain
Your Majesty I would like to enclose to
the evidence the description of one
therapy conducted by the defendant which
as we can read also finished with a
failure the girl with similar illness
like Edward who under the influence of
the therapy made suicide and did the
defendant realized that his wife was
pregnant not with him but with Edward I
haven't no idea what's going on name
work I really have no idea I've worried
no idea
yeah there they make it a walk for in
this game OSs
a friend of the accused
like I really have no idea I totally
lost at this point where is it so who
killed who Eddie got the doctor's wife
pregnant and then killed everybody what
yeah okay I know you don't pay me so I'm
taking my sway time
is this your office
[Music]
mother say Wilson murdered
all the harbucks making about the father
or the family
okay and I started to live on memories
and projections that were so beautiful
in my head that's been perfect years
before like when we moved into our new
house and we plan to make a big garden
only for us these memories made me
stronger helped me to survive and wait
for tomorrow with hope first time I
thought that maybe I'm only dreaming or
the projections about him became
ridiculously strong he came to me like
before
smiling similar situations repeated in
the next weeks and I instead of looking
for their source was waiting till my
loving Steven came back just for a while
lucky years ago at the beginning of our
relationship Steven often told me about
interesting things from the psychology
work hearing is that you seem that with
the case of multiple spelled wrong with
multiple personalities I remember well
this case yeah these people like do this
in like one second
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's split personality Eddie's
just another personality last resort I
will send this recording to Abraham okay
Eddie no that's why we of course
chorim's so confusing yeah great
all right can you leave me alone I'm
just I'm just trying to get to the door
again
14:08 well that's what this okay
abdominis time
what at the Xavier I see if I stay back
which would have example yep okay there
we go
there's my magazine really care Wow
Stark
all right
what what is for the bird thing is here
I'd like the psychology of birds like it
yeah great alright just lost the
monetization on this one
wait what are then
[Music]
yeah guys nothing
oh my god
what the guy not here
[Music]
attack attack
[Music]
okay that's an event I hope y'all people
enjoy that is a really a verge game like
maybe like Saran attend
ah yeah
anyhow guys